[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this session That's
about Optiva and Cloud Spanner.
My name is Deepti Srivastava.
I'm the product manager for
Cloud Spanner in the cloud
databases and storage team.
And it is my great pleasure
to open this session
for all of us.
So Optiva, previously
Redknee Solutions,,
is a telco based
software company.
And as a lot of you
may know, telco systems
are some of the most
demanding in the world.
And so as Optiva looks
to look to the cloud
to gain competitive
advantage and also
to embrace new technology,
they settled on Cloud Spanner
fairly quickly, right.
And that's what we're
here to talk about today.
But before that, so
Optiva has replatformed
to use Cloud Scanner for
their new billing and charging
system, and recently, we
announced a partnership
with Optiva at Mobile World
Congress earlier this year.
We're very excited
about that partnership.
It's a great partnership.
And we are so grateful and
so appreciative seeing Optiva
actually move a very traditional
telco industry into the cloud.
We're also excited
that they have
moved to GCP for their
internal IT services as well.
So to tell you all
about this journey,
it is my great
honor and pleasure
to introduce Danielle Royston,
who is the CEO of Optiva.
DANIELLE ROYSTONE: Yeah.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Welcome, Danielle.
DANIELLE ROYSTONE: Hi.
Thank you so much.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
DANIELLE ROYSTONE: Yeah.
Thank you.
Welcome everyone.
Thank you, Deepti, for
that great introduction.
And hopefully the volume
is OK and I'm not too loud.
I get really excited.
That's kind of who I am.
Danielle Roystone, everyone
calls me DR, by my initials.
I'm not a doctor.
I'm CEO of Optiva, as
Deepti explained, and let
me get my little clicker here.
So yeah.
So Deepti was talking
about Cloud Spanner.
This is Google's
enterprise database
that we have decided
to start to use.
And we're really excited
about this partnership, right.
Google, obviously one of the
best companies in the world,
and Optiva is a little small
company, about $120 million
of revenue, based
in Toronto, Canada.
I actually live
in Austin, Texas,
and I became the CEO of this
company about 18 months ago.
And 18 months ago, this company
was on the verge of bankruptcy,
right.
It was about to die.
We had about 100 customers
running our product,
and it worked, but the
company kind of lost its way.
What I do is, I'm
a turn around CEO.
I go in, I'm kind of
like Winston Wolfe
from Pulp Fiction.
I'm the fixer, right.
I go in and I fix problems.
And so I sat down and looked
at the company, looked
at our assets, what
was working well,
what did customers really
like about us, what could
we do better.
And one of the
things we looked at
was, we could do more with the
vision around the products.
So we really started
to investigate that.
So as Deepti explained, we
make software for telcos,
and specifically it's
called charging software.
It sounds boring as hell,
and when I first came in,
I was like, what is
this, what are we doing.
But I will explain what
that is in a second here.
So yeah, that's me.
That's my cool little
comets, because I'm coming
to change everything in telco.
All right, so what
is charging, right.
Everyone here, I see
everyone has a phone,
and all your phones
have plans, right.
The telcos come up
with designs to get
you to become a subscriber,
that's like a customer to them,
number of minutes, number of
texts, the amount of data.
And so there's
marketing teams that
design those plans to entice
you to become a customer
and stay with them.
And then as you're making phone
calls, as you're sending text,
there is software
somewhere, usually sitting
on their network,
usually sitting
on the ground on premise,
that's tracking your calls
and deducting them
from your plan.
And so the United States is
largely a postpaid market,
meaning we pay our bills
after the month is over,
but the world is largely
a prepaid market, right.
Most people are paying
for it ahead of time,
and then when they're out
of minutes or out of data,
it stops you, right.
So this, it needs to
be correct, right.
It's a very technically
difficult problem
to solve, right.
It's revenue, right, so if
the calculation is ever wrong,
these guys are not being able
to calculate revenue, which
is obviously their business.
Number two, it's super
high volume, right.
Think of all the
people in the country
simultaneously making calls and
doing texts, so lots of volume
going on.
And it has to be low latency,
right, so when you make a call,
you're not going to sit there
and wait for the charging
engine to return in a minute.
It has to be
milliseconds of time.
So it's a super difficult,
technical problem to solve,
and I call it the
trifecta of hard, right.
Transactional integrity, has
to be computing correctly.
Low latency, and this is
high growth, high volume.
Now, all of us
are-- or most of us,
maybe I have a
couple of Canadians.
I know I have a
But you know, we kind
of think of the US
as like this really big
market, and the world
revolves around us.
But the reality is,
we are tiny compared
to some of these other markets
like India and China, right.
And so we have a
customer located in India
that has 200
million subscribers.
And so imagine all of
us in the United States,
we just had one telco.
We were all there,
and there wasn't
choices like Verizon and AT&T
and Sprint and T-Mobile, right.
We have a customer
that is basically
the size of the United
States, and so for them, this
is a really hard
problem for us to solve.
When we install our
products like I said,
traditionally on the ground,
we use Oracle, right.
Oracle's known as maybe
the world's best enterprise
database.
Its super trusted, it works,
it handles a lot of volume,
and for us, we can
process in our engine
about 50,000 transactions
per second, which is a lot.
And that's good, but
for our India customer,
for example, it's not enough.
And so our solution
there is to stand up
copies of the implementation
around the country in India
to handle urban circles.
So think of a city or a city
area as an urban circle.
I have 12
implementations, and so
its kind of like 12
customers in one.
Like I have a Delhi, I have
a Mumbai, right, Calcutta.
I have all these
different areas where
they are handling the traffic.
But I need to have a consistent
database because people move,
right.
You don't just stay in one spot.
So these guys, the database
has to talk to each other,
I got to keep it up.
And so today, we have
essentially 12 data centers
with testing, staging,
production, disaster recovery,
right.
There's a really good
story about our customer
where their data center
started to flood in India,
and our team got
caught in the building.
And they were just
like lifting up
the machines off of the ground.
I guess that's one
way of getting cloud.
But they just
started like lifting
the machines to save them.
And our team actually,
I just saw this video,
our team actually got
caught in the building
for like three days, they
slept there, no food,
like managing the machines.
All right, so like I said,
50,000 transactions per second
is pretty much our limit.
And you know, being a
tough, hard problem,
Oracle really owns
the telco space.
Like, they're everywhere,
and some of our customers
pay between $10 million and
$100 million a year to Oracle.
Oracle is notoriously difficult
to do business with, right.
My customers have told me
that they try to get off,
and Oracle just increases
the price, right.
So if you're paying
$100 million,
and you figured out a way
to carve out $20 million,
they figure out a way to
still charge you $100 million.
And so our customers were
like, you know, what can we do.
Now, there's a lot of
database vendors out there
and we certainly looked
at a lot of them,
but we were like, you know,
to really change this problem
and come up with a fresh idea,
we went to the engineering team
and said, could we make our
product 10 times faster, right.
Assuming that there's
nothing stopping you,
right, change out Oracle,
change out the coding,
rewrite the whole entire engine.
What could we do, right.
Sky's the limit.
And we started to look
at the database, right.
This is a write
intensive application.
It's not just, you
know, look it up,
return an answer to the user.
You actually have to deduct
five minutes from the plan
and write it to the database.
Meanwhile, if you're like me,
I'm like texting on my phone
and then doing
something on my watch,
and you know, I'm
on my iPad, right.
So atomically correct actions
need to be captured and written
to the database.
And so we noticed that
a lot of the performance
of our application was spent
writing to the database.
So that's kind of got
us like on the trail of,
maybe we could do something
with a different database.
We looked at a bunch
of different databases,
and basically we're
like, what can we do.
Around this time, so
I started in February.
I think Spanner was
announced in March.
Valentine's Day, OK.
That was the day
I started Optiva.
I didn't realize that.
So that was the day
I started Optiva.
And so we were
looking, we were like,
what can we do, how can we
make this 10 times faster.
And we read the Spanner press
release, and we're like,
are you kidding me.
Like, this is our
dream come true, right.
We have a perfect
database that can handle
the transactional volume.
It's distributed,
it's consistent,
multiple writings,
like synchronized
writing across 1,000 servers.
It's exactly what we needed
to replace big bad Oracle.
And it had the Google name,
so that our customers woulf
trust it, right.
I mean, they're not
going to just switch to--
not to disparage any
databases out there,
but you know, NuoDB or
MongoDB or whatever.
My customers are like, these are
$10 billion dollar companies.
They're like, we need
a good strong name.
So we looked at Spanner and
we're like, this could work.
This might work.
So I called up my
friends at Google.
Dom, Dom's here.
I called, I literally
like sent him an email
and was like, hey, Dom,
you haven't heard from me
in, I don't know, 19 years.
Yeah.
But I just read this really
awesome press release,
and we think it could work.
And it was really new.
And so we put
together two teams,
and we just started working on
the problem, just go, right,
can we make it 10 times faster.
And it was pretty easy to make
it 10 times faster, right.
I'll talk about it in a
second, about like what we did,
but you know, the fact
is, it was such a game
changer for telco that we would
have put our entire engineering
budget behind getting it to work
with Spanner if it was required
because it was such a
revolutionary database.
So that was really cool.
So let's see.
Yeah.
So I have a demo here.
I'm going to attempt to click.
All right.
When can you go ahead and
switch it to the demo?
So try to make
performance like cool,
and it's actually really hard
for performance to be cool.
So the other thing
we wanted to do
besides making it 10 times
faster, we wanted to make sure
it was a tenth of the cost.
It needed to be also
cheaper than Oracle, right.
So again, this system
works for the telcos.
It's running their revenue.
They're not going to
move off of a system
if it's just two times faster.
It's just not enough.
Or four times faster.
Now, it had to be
10 times faster,
so it had to be big enough
for a reason to change,
but the same time, if it's
10 times as expensive,
they're also not going to move.
So our second goal that
we started working on
was, could we make it
a tenth of the cost.
And that's the beauty
of the cloud, right.
That's the beauty of Spanner.
So what we have here is,
this is a live demo, right,
so it's not a video.
It's a real demo.
What you see over
here are transactions.
These are call records of users.
You can see kind
of what's going on,
right, what they're
using, what the story is.
Over here is the transactions
per second, and I bumped it up.
I actually need to bump
it up a little bit more.
It's at 300.
So this is live.
I'm going to just
take it up to 500,000
transactions per second.
And so the engine,
what Spanner is doing
is dynamically deploying
nodes in Google Cloud
live right now to
build up to this level.
So imagine what happens
in a country when
like an earthquake happens, or
you know, it's Christmas Day
and everyone's making
their family calls.
You would get this temporary
spike in usage, you know,
or World Cup, right.
We just went through World Cup.
It was like a month long,
lots more usage of video
on the phone.
But then after World
Cup, the volume drops.
What my customers do
is, they provision
to like just above what they
think they need on their worst
day, because they get the media
attention when they're down,
when things aren't working.
So they need to have data
centers and the capacity
to compute already hot and
live, plus the disaster
recovery for all of that, to
be able to handle their best
day or their worst
day, depending
on how you look at it, right.
What's so great about
Spanner is that it's
deploying dynamically.
So maybe there was
an unexpected event,
you know, a negative
event in the country,
a terrorist attack,
right, an earthquake.
You get these spikes, and by
running in the public cloud
and specifically
running with Spanner,
I now no longer need to
deploy Oracle instances.
Now, over here is the big
bad line of Oracle spend.
Every time that's spiking, I'm
deploying another data center
that's provisioned for
usually equal capacity.
So if you're the
customer in India,
right, you have a
system running about
and handling about 50,000
transactions per second.
And now you need to
handle more volume,
usually what they
do is they just
set up another data center
that handles that capacity.
You don't need
all that capacity,
but you pre-purchase all the
compute and all the power
to be able to handle that.
What's nice about Spanner
is, I can go back down
and all that spend
comes back down.
So a lot of times,
when people look
at public cloud, for
our industry, for telco,
we're really kind
of behind everyone.
Everyone's still running
in closets on sites, right.
Maybe some have virtualized.
No one's in public cloud.
In fact, when I
started, my team was
like don't talk about Google.
Don't talk about public cloud.
It's like really bad.
They're never going to do it.
And I'm like, this is insane.
Like, public cloud
is everywhere.
It's absolutely coming to telco.
And so it's like kind
of behind, but now we're
bringing them to the
future here, right.
The cloud is now.
So they over-provision,
they pay for all this stuff.
With Spanner, I don't
have to do that.
And to show you that it's
live, if I Alt Tab over here,
this is the Google
product, right,
showing the transactions.
You can see at 11 whatever--
why does it say 11:45?
Maybe 12:45.
Maybe it's off on the time.
It spiked when I moved it up.
The nodes-- I forget why
the nodes are consistent.
Maybe [INAUDIBLE] can remind me.
But you can see the transaction.
So this is live running
in Google Cloud.
Someone's paying
for it, probably me.
I'll probably take down the
transactions after this, right,
because it's kind of too much.
Remind me to take it down.
So this is a game changer
for telco and for us.
So hold on.
Let me look at my
notes one more time.
Let's see here.
I talked without
looking at my notes.
All right, so why does this--
actually go back to the screen.
Awesome.
So why does this work, right.
So sure, Oracle can
do clusters and can
kind of replicate multi-writing,
but the difference with Spanner
is, I need to be distributed
across like thousands
of servers, right, and I
need that strong consistency.
So Oracle can't do that, right.
I mean, I can create a cluster
of like maybe 50 Oracle
databases, but
Spanner's doing it
all for me behind the scenes.
I have to have
global scale, right.
My telcos have
multiple data centers,
like my India example has 12.
But Google, I mean, I
have the whole Google
footprint behind us, billions
of dollars of investment.
And I need to have
performance at scale.
I can't have a choke
point for my writes
like I do with Oracle.
And so because of Spanner's
true time functionality,
where it's atomically
synchronizing all the writes,
this works for me.
So I am correct.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DANIELLE ROYSTONE:
I can't hear you.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a
bunch of Chinese customers?
DANIELLE ROYSTONE: I don't
have any Chinese customers.
I have an India customer.
Yeah.
OK, cool.
So I forgot where I
was, but it's cool.
I'll figure it out.
Say that again?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: [INAUDIBLE]
DANIELLE ROYSTONE:
Yes, thank you, Deepti.
I was like where'd she go,
did she leave me, right.
So the true time
piece, and Deepti
will be able to explain
this much better than me,
but the whole idea
behind true time
is the ability to write
asynchronously and keep
everything in sync atomically.
So I no longer have a chokepoint
like I do with Oracle,
and it's all being handled
for me dynamically,
which is amazing.
And we think that the
last piece, the true time,
is really where there's
technical differentiation here
versus Oracle.
This is not just
any other database.
This isn't marketing
fluff that we fell for.
You know, oh, we
like Google, let's
just pick Google's database.
We looked at a bunch
of different databases.
And we're like, these are
three distinct reasons
that it's not only as good
as Oracle, which currently
is regarded as maybe one
of the best databases,
it's actually better,
right, and now
it supports the dynamic
scaling that my telcos need,
so they're not provisioning
data center after data center
at the same cost.
I'm saving them money, and
now my promise of 10 times
faster at a tenth
of the cost is true.
So again, I'm in India.
My team's like,
don't tell the story
about Oracle and public cloud.
And I'm like, I'm going to do
it, I'm going to talk about it,
this is like an
amazing idea, and I'm
talking to the
technical leaders,
and their heads just spin when
I tell them 10 times faster
at a tenth of the cost.
They're like, what did you say.
And I was like,
yeah, I don't think
you'll be interested in
it because you're so big,
you know, you have
your own data centers.
My team tells me you'll
never pick public cloud.
They're like, can we start
a proof of concept tomorrow.
And so off we go.
And so that's when I
knew we were really
onto a really competitive
differentiation for us
as a company, and we were
going to really change
the landscape for telco.
All right.
Migrating your application.
Like I said, I think
I said this earlier,
for us it was pretty easy.
We had a database layer
in our application.
We were able to just switch
out from basically SQL to RPC,
and then we started
performance benchmarking it,
and it was 10 times faster.
I mean, that sounds easy.
I'm sure if the engineers
that worked on it were here,
they'd be like, uh, a little
bit more went into that work.
But I'd say within 90
days, we had something
that was 10 times faster,
and then within six months,
we had something that was
10 times cheaper, right.
So at first, we were deploying
like a ridiculous number
of nodes, and then later we got
a little bit more efficient,
so that was cool.
We think there's still room to
make this even faster, right.
So 10 times, I mean, like
I said, turning heads.
I have a lot of customers that
are in the audience, right.
We spent time yesterday
talking about it.
You know, they're
excited about it as well.
So it's working for small
telcos, for super big telcos.
It's a really great idea.
We think there's still two
more features of Spanner
that we could do to take it
kind of to the next level
if we ever needed to.
They have an interesting
parent child relationship
with the data, so
you can kind of
bring your data closer together,
so that when we do a look up
on a particular customer's
plan, it's a little bit faster.
And so we're not doing
that yet, but we could.
And then we could
look at the way
we're designing our
database transaction
boundaries so that
it's a little bit more
efficient and optimized.
We haven't done that.
Right now, we're really
focused on getting this older--
I mean, this application
is 15 years old, right.
This isn't like
Instagram, Snapchat.
It's like old and boring, like
I said at the beginning, right,
but it's running billions
of dollars of monetization
for the telcos of the world.
Every telco has a
product like this.
Some cases, they have multiple
products running, right.
So we think this is incredible
technology, game changing
computer science stuff, and so
we're super excited about that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]